back off i'm benching trubisky do you
think he's coming back i don't know
i'm going to lie to god
oh no oh oh my bad everyone i won't
trade you master trumisky
i can't because that would be i messed
up not gonna lie
my confidence is pretty low right now
stay uh away from my team falls please
you merely adopted controversy i was
born
you know once again i found myself in a
hole how did comic book world got wacky
out there okay
which of us is starting dolphin men
i'm still learning and washington to the
playoffs but without asking
no i renounced my wish
7 yard screen pass i did it i threw left
come with me you don't owe these people
anything they do constantly bring up the
whole
holmes watson thing but we must fight
cat man man you play for the jags once
and that
follows you forever sorry to blow up
your playoff chances we want the fight
put mitch in now i'm a good coach yo we
already blew it you're good bro i'm
gonna go bomb on the road
[Music]
because he's not the hero chicago
deserves but the one it needs right now
oh wait no is it the other way no he's
the hero we don't want but ha
no no he's the hero we deserve but
shouldn't
extend no no he's the hero we don't want
i'm the hero
we deserve